let me get my first guest on the line
he's a man on a mission to make sure we
all stay informed during this tough time
he's the anchor of NBC Nightly News and
Dateline and recently he added one more
NBC Nightly News kids edition
all right molester are you there I am
hey I'm doing okay I mean I'm I'm trying
to abide by the rules and you know I
stand on my head if they told me you
would flatten the curve so you know
other than walking the dog you know a
couple times a day and make it
occasional food run son
I'm at home but where is your home it's
beautiful yeah this is my home in lower
Manhattan and you know it's a fort
fortunately we you know we done some
work you we got in just in time on all
this here yeah you just can't complain
in times like this because you know a
lot of folks can't like us work at home
so you know we're doing we got to do ya
know amen I feel like and what's funny
about your statement is we have been
living in temporary housing and the
school yard show going on right now what
would you have said you know what would
you been sad about I guess to miss at
the end of your high school experience
oh you know you know so much happens in
that last month I think one of the cool
things I don't know if they do this
anymore of a grant in California
Disneyland used to have grad night and
they would close the park from midnight
to 5:00 a.m. and high school graduates
from all over the West would come and
then just have a fun night and I
remember I really looked forward to that
I hate to miss that because it was a was
like a celebration not only with your
classmates but it was you know other you
know 18 year olds or ahead that and so
fun all right well you're doing the
virtual commencement speech this year at
Fort liquors yeah yeah Rutgers uh they
asked me to be a commencement speaker
and and you know like a lot of schools
are not gonna have a traditional
commencement so I'll be doing it in
front of a camera I often thought about
this because you see a lot of people in
the limelight giving commencement
speeches and I'm like gosh that's got to
be nerve-wracking right like what are
you gonna say yeah I've done you know
I've done commencement speeches before
it it's always awkward for me because I
didn't finish college so I always have
to like do that as
you know announcement that hey you know
I never stood where you guys are right
now but it's a different message this
year because they're going on into a job
market that's essentially zilch right
now in terms of opportunities I think my
message stem is going to be this is your
story to tell you are the generation
that is coming out of this thing you're
gonna know how it ends because we'll be
playing out this through years and I
want them to think about that think
about you know what are we learning
right now that we can apply you know I'm
dying to know how this you know how this
all ends and and how it changes us
changes of the world will we stop start
looking at you know issues like climate
change differently now because now we're
seeing that bad things can really be
possible some of those things that
people may have warned us about that we
never heard now we're hearing it and now
we get it that all these people that toy
away in labs and academic settings you
know going over statistics and
possibilities that stuff can really
happen doing less we're dealing with the
virus is hard enough for grownups tell
me about the newscast you're doing just
for kids like how is that going yeah we
um one of our senior producers say why
don't we you know this is all so scary
why don't we do a show aimed at kids and
immediately we're like yeah that makes
sense because I have to tell you there
was some nights I'd be anchoring the
news and I'd be listening to the words
coming out of my mouth I'm thinking oh
my goodness their family's watching
their children watching right now and
there's no way to really you know tell
these stories in a way that we can
comfort you know their particular needs
so this was a great opportunity so we
don't shy away from the bad news we
acknowledge this is scary but we try and
you know put it in some perspective
about you know ways that people are
helping ways people are inspiring each
other questions that kids may have about
you know can my pet get the disease
those sorts of things and so we allow
the kids to send in their video
questions and we try and deal with it
with our experts and then have some fun
moments but it's gone over really well
really proud of it thank you so much for
keeping us all informed for one thing
but is this the hardest thing you've
ever had to report on because I know
you've had you have so many jobs you've
reported a lot but is this kind of
really hard and devastating no I mean
it's really the biggest story I've ever
covered
I've covered a lot of horrible stories
involving a lot of suffering um you know
the horrible earthquake several years
ago in in Haiti that had a staggering
death toll and I covered your famine and
Somalia so I've seen a lot of suffering
but this this story has so many moving
parts I mean obviously it's this health
calamity but it's also this huge
economic disaster we're watching unfold
and you know these are things that both
of those prongs are not going to be easy
to fix in a short term and we guess we
may get a vaccine we may get better
treatments you know in the medical side
but still there's a lot of people on
this planet who need those medicines and
things and the same thing on the on the
economic side I mean the damage is
mounting every day yes yes true um was
there one particular image or moment
when the seriousness of it all really
hit you because I feel like it's been in
different moments for everyone yeah I
mean obviously I deal in moments but I
think I think it was one day toward the
last few days that I was broadcasting
from a studio versus my home I was kind
of holed up in my office and I opened
the door one day and I couldn't see
anybody and it was weird I'm at 30
Rockefeller Plaza
you know the nightly news newsroom and
we had so quickly moved people to work
off-site and it just hit me that one day
when I realize there's just not a lot of
people around here right now and I think
that's when oh this is Lucy hi Lucy oh
my gosh what kind of dog I have the
Henry and Henry looks similar Oh Lucy is
a four year old Australian Labradoodle
okay I have a goldendoodle approach
works within Australian accents very
strict um I mean I love I've always
loved dogs but during this period do you
not find your hugging your dog more and
petting your dog more my dog is in
heaven because I work so much and you do
too because I listed off all of your
jobs but like I'm around him so much now
and he can come with me cuz I'm on the
ranch and he kind of comes and goes with
me all the time now he's gonna he's
gonna go into a depression once we all
go back to work yeah we were and he's
and dogs are so healing like they're so
I don't know what it is about their
little spirits but like even just laying
with him I've been in a bad mood just
laying down on the floor then just like
cuddling with Henry because he's a big
dog kind of like it looks Lucy is but
but um he's a bigger dog and it's it's
just so comforting right it is
comforting and I'm feeling we were
talking about this just today that oh my
goodness when I go back to work she's
gonna be in depression they're all gonna
throw parties when we're gone doing the
news from home like because I feel I
feel like me doing the Voisin and the
talk show and recording the record it is
hard in this circumstance but at the
same time like right now I'm wearing
just like gym pants and you can't talk
yeah I mean there is comfort I put on a
suit and tie and yes I wear pants but I
felt like I hit rock bottom one day I
was doing the newscast middle of nightly
news and I looked in I realized pulling
in some barefoot and and it horf it
horrified me obviously the audience
couldn't see it but I'm like oh my
goodness this is where I met oh look at
you there's no bar anymore I've just
gone solo no it's but there's some
advantages and I work alone so I mean I
had to learn how to flip some switches
and buttons and turn some lights on but
I have a great bathroom access which you
know big long Newsday is always good so
you know cuz I'm like you I'm not a tech
person so I'm having to learn how to do
all this stuff behind the scenes too and
you really start to go thank you so much
to my crew I already really appreciate
my crew but like you really appreciate
your crew in this moment and all that
they do and then little things that kind
of add up but yeah I was doing a
newscast the other night and and it was
like 10 minutes before air and no one
was talking to me through my earpiece
but I didn't think anything of it
sometimes aren't they're busy and then I
hear the phone ring that my wife comes
to Ronnie and she goes yeah I have
so somehow my communications at captain
studio and so then they kicked up a
whole bunch of things I had to dial back
in but so she's my tech manager actually
and we have no idea what we're doing
well I see that bass behind you and I'm
just curious I mean can I convince you
to play just a little something maybe or
yes well you know I don't know if I have
any bases nearby but if I did I love it
[Music]
in life when we can be within six feet
of each other we got to do something
together I want to sing while you play
bass that's what I'm talking about I
would love that I you know I have them I
always play my bases but I find it's
like that
it's become a ritual now before my
newscast I put on some music at my
little home office and then I started
jamming and then it kind of gets me in
this like headspace to do the news every
night so it's fine thanks for asking I
love it I love I like I was telling you
before my bass player is so amazing
he'll go like how you ever have bright
bass back there he'll go you know from
from different kind of bases and it's
just such a smooth sound and people know
this but actually they always think it's
the Germans to base the drums that
really hold down the rhythm and
everything of a set yeah if you pull out
the bass track you know you would
realize how much a part of you you know
you don't often hear it consciously but
man you take it you remove it from music
and everything changes and then it's
like wait where's the where's the beat
and where's everything yeah it's it's
it's so cool sounding - it's a sexy
instrument alright yo you can catch
Nightly News kids edition on NBC News
comm the Embassy News YouTube page and
also peacock
also catch Lester on NBC Nightly News on
NBC as well he's got a lot of jobs I'll
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going